on the trains on the roads and at
airports strike action is bringing
Britain's transport Network to a halt
all in time for Christmas
thousands of Railway workers are
expected to go on strike with Road
workers and Airport baggage handlers
joining the action
it has the potential to cause widespread
disruption for businesses I spoke
briefly to Kim earlier she was saying
it's um it's currently about 50 percent
This Bar in central London lost half of
its bookings during the last week of
strike action and almost all at its
sister site I mean it's brutal this is
our this is our this is our time to go
and we lost last year we just opened
because of covid so
it's going to be devastating I mean I'm
sympathetic to the workers how can you
not be we we hire 60 people like if if
we didn't pay them well I'd expect them
to strike and I expect them to have
problems but um I don't feel like this
is hitting the people that matter with
inflation at a 41-year high workers are
fighting for pay Rises but businesses
like this one are on the firing line
December is crunch time for businesses
in the hospitality and Retail sectors
after a difficult two years Christmas
parties are back on the agenda and
Shoppers should start hitting the high
streets once more
but rail strikes threatened to derail
this recovery it could lead to billions
in Lost sales and smaller paychecks this
month for those who can't get to work
something nice for Christmas might be
good while the costs are piling up for
businesses ministers and Union buses are
locked in battle we've had a meeting
with the minister and all the parties
and talks will continue today and over
the weekend so we'll see see where we go
from there the government says that
higher pay Rises could push up inflation
but it's facing pressure from across the
public sector unless it can thrash out a
deal
Britain faces strikes every day until
Christmas
Sky News